John Krasinski favorite Office episode
wow that's a hard question to answer I
would have to say my favorite Office
episode was diversity day it was
technically the second episode but it
was the first episode of our own meaning
the pilot was a direct copy of the
British show the whole script was the
exact pilot of the British show so
diversity day was our first episode that
was ours and ours alone and I will never
forget that because being in that room
Not only was I the most unprofessional
actor because I laughed at every single
thing that happened and I totally
through the being in a documentary out
the window I was like no I'm gonna laugh
at everything all these people do but I
remember feeling in the room and looking
around all these people who didn't think
anyone was going to watch this show and
we still didn't think anyone would watch
the show but I said this is going to be
one of the funniest things that's ever
been recorded on television too bad no
one will see it because who knows where
this show goes